[Music]
this place this thing we've created is
very special everybody who steps onto
this land I don't care if you've walked
up with a angry face you're gonna leave
with a smile
[Music]
pulled off your urban creators we are a
collective that have the responsibility
in the honor of stewarding this land the
urban creators has really become a space
that is feeding so many people in this
community and more importantly it's a
space where people can learn how to grow
their own food there's only one grocery
store in this area which is very far
considering how dense this neighborhood
is
[Music]
everyone should be provided fresh food
period and the fact that that is
inaccessible to so many communities
around the country is a problem that
urban farming permaculture folks that
are in these types of industries are
trying to solve we combat food and
justice by educating young people on
urban agriculture and employing young
people to be farmers to be growers and
to be entrepreneurs in those industries
farmers keep is actually the only
restaurant that we supply our food to
because our community is a priority but
partnerships like this give us a chance
to have earned income so that we're
self-reliant here at the farm we grow a
lot of different things to feed a lot of
different people but growing food isn't
the only thing that we do here at the
farm
we're totally 100 organic farm so we
make our own compost here we collect our
own water we have chickens to me the
urban creators is really a platform to
support radical and collaborative
imagination this has been an experiment
in like love and creativity for everyone
involved
my particular mission for urban creators
is to teach young people basic carpentry
skills the skill that they can actually
use in life that's gonna take them
farther than just sell it
[Music]
not only do we practice urban
agriculture here we're also a safe space
for young people and we provide artistic
and cultural experiences it is rare that
people get to take a break and just
celebrate or just experience joy with
their communities and I think that is
another strategy and tool that breaks
down systemic problems because yeah we
have to fight it with love we have to
fight it with passion and we have to
fight it with a smile on our face the
only way that people have ever been able
to transform anything is in community
and in union with each other
grab your friends find something that
you guys are all passionate about and
take that and make it a dream and make
it come true
somebody got to do it first so we do it
in this show people how to do it and
prove that it works
we don't need everybody to copy what we
do but I will love like for a lot of my
young people to take this to where they
live it
anything is possible which people can
you know get up and do anything you want
whenever you decide to do it
[Music]